with russian president vladimir putin's
main rival alexey navalny in jail
and his anti-corruption foundation now
declared an extremist organization
putin's administration has effectively
closed off
almost all avenues of legitimate
opposition to his government
all was bad in this trial we couldn't
even talk about any sort
of adversarial system or equality
because we filed some 25 petitions and
all of them were rejected the judge
didn't want to hear us though we made
mincemeat of all the so-called evidence
brought by the prosecution
the authorities now have the formal
power to jail activists and freeze their
assets
navalny's allies had already disbanded
their groups in anticipation of this
ruling
another opposition politician dmitry
goodkov has gone to ukraine
after being warned by people close to
the kremlin that he'd be arrested if he
stayed in russia
most prominent anti-government activists
are now either in jail
under house arrest or have fled the
country
my aunt is under travel restrictions
they gave me a hint that they would put
her in jail at any moment
she's 60 and not ready for anything like
this
this is andre pavavarov the director of
the now defunct open russia
an opposition group linked to exiled oil
tycoon and kremlin critic
mikhail hordakovsky
[Music]
in the kremlin everyone knew i was going
to run for parliament he said
after being taken off a flight last week
that was about to take off for poland
from saint petersburg
he's suspected of violating legislation
on undesirable organizations
the court ruling bans alexi navalny's
allies from parliamentary elections
later this year
leaving few options for those wanting to
take on putin's united russia party
this looks like the final blow to a
political network built up over years by
alexei navalny
to challenge vladimir putin the
opposition politicians supporters
say they'll still try to use tactical
voting to undermine support
for the pro-kremlin united russia party
bernard smith al jazeera moscow